carlstadt new jersey
a small industrial town buried in the
shadow of meadowland stadium only a mile
away sits the grasshopper also a
family-owned irish pub and restaurant hi
how are you girls how you doing all
right good
17 years ago newlyweds mitch and maureen
sandler purchased the restaurant with
maureen's father a successful
restaurateur with 40 years of experience
in the business we were excited because
you have dreams and you say okay let's
go for it so that's what we did ready to
rock and roll right yeah let's go it's
gonna be good it took off we were
booming enjoy your meal people were
coming in left and right all right this
way please and as the years rolled by
things started to change in the business
[Music]
obviously it's dead tonight just go home
okay as far as why the restaurant is
failing
i don't know what time is there coming
up tomorrow i don't
this is a nightmare because mitch
where's that gun i have no idea
this supervision is
not what it should be
mitch you gotta come out here yeah
mitch is responsible for the kitchen
what am i doing in here he's in this
restaurant a ridiculous amount of hours
and a majority of those hours are not
productive hey uh where's the toilet
plunger can i get a bar mop please how
are you good there's daily operations of
the restaurant that he absolutely should
not be involved in
maybe he could commit more of his time
to oversee stuff that is you know uh in
the kitchen all the other stuff has to
be done that you're not taking care of
you're doing all that other stuff
communication between mitchell and his
staff is
non-existent hey uh how long does it
take to make rice
[Music]
the guys don't probably think it's a
problem
[Music]
and because of that the food at the
grasshopper
just looks awful they didn't like they
didn't say there was a lot of flavor in
it it is so dry he doesn't like this
that's perfect at stake
it was rare which won't take no
responsibility of uh quality control
mitch you call this soup get rid of this
[ __ ] my father-in-law blames me for
everything so i'm the scapegoat there's
nobody here it's horrible
meet some people
if we continue this way we're not gonna
make it i feel like my life is falling
apart
it's pretty tough
every day i think about the restaurant
it's all on my shoulders
and every day it eats at me
we cannot afford this well that's why we
need some help here if chef ramsey
can't help me
i don't know where else to turn
it's the last resort
[Music]
oh hello hi chef ramsay maureen sandler
nice to meet you guys good to see you
too okay this is my dad eddie fantastic
chef ramsay welcome i thought you were a
small little buck no no no this is my
favorite hi chef how are you pleasure
we're co-owners so the three of you are
running the business together yes wow i
should really stand between these two
guys because that's usually the case
why did you say that we vote heads
occasionally occasionally are you
kidding we almost kill each other
yeah okay wow you're already refereeing
these two
i mean who does what i'm the one that's
overseas in the kitchen okay so i'd like
to get up to speed okay with you
individually and have a quick chat
come on this way
i'm the one that takes care of the bills
and it's getting tougher and tougher so
we need chef ramsay's help
the fact that you stood in the middle of
those two guys is it really that bad or
business has changed drastically and my
father has to blame somebody and he
blames my husband where does your
allegiance lie with my husband you know
i support him
how much it costs to build this three
million to get it going
that's crazy what do you think is wrong
with a business
mitch is
one of the biggest problems do you
regret now 16 years later given in part
of the business yes
tell me
the biggest issue inside grasshopper my
father-in-law blames me for everything
but is he right or was he wrong
he could be right
could be wrong
who's running it i guess i am right
let's talk about the food um people seem
to like it lovely i can't wait to taste
that enjoy your traditional irish food's
good here i think you'll like the food i
hope
hello hi how are you
good first name is ramsay annette nice
to see you very nice to meet you and you
are
the floor manager here
also how long have you been here i've
worked in this one for 16 years so
you've been here from day one day one
what's wrong with the russians
um
start to the top
management or lack of very frustrating
well i love your uh honesty on a scale
of one to ten what would you weigh the
food
you're three
the cooks are winging it i don't know
what is that
i don't think care goes into every dish
that they're making
[Music]
okay have you decided or let's go for
the french onion soup okay shepherd's
pie and i'll go for fisherman's platter
fantastic hungry hey oh yes
uh dying to get my head around what's
going on
all right what's he having first things
first we'd like a french onion soup
thank you
unbelievable lambs from another era
these pumpkins maybe my grandmother's
luggage
unbelievable let me chase this
yes so it tastes black tar
i think it's pretty good
do you want uh yes okay
mitch is serving the food which i told
him completely wrong but unfortunately
he doesn't know what he's doing in here
enjoy thank you
jesus it's like somebody's dropped
sliced onions into boiling dishwater
dreadful
how's the french onion yeah after a bed
stand unfortunately
it's like someone's pissed in my soup
[Music]
well that's not good we'll take this
away
[Music]
that was dreadful
all right um guys the french onion he
said it's like piss
flavor he said it was not good
[Music]
i told you that onion soup wasn't right
we know i know
well how are you going to go educate
these guys right i don't know i'll find
out the kitchen staff will do what they
want to do and do as little as possible
which should grab the ball by the horns
and be in command all right shepherd's
pie here we go thank you gabriel he
makes a good shepherd's pie
all right chef
thank you shepherd's pie
wow that's a very bizarre looking sugar
pie someone put gravy on top of my
crispy mash yes that is a shocker like
someone's snot all over my mash
and that gravy is made from beef
beef stock on the shepherd's pie
shepherd's pie is made out of this one
is actually beef there's a cottage pie
not a shepherd's pie because shepherd
stands for the
sheep
i'll be about to check on you
cold congealed gravy it's like
glue
so how are we doing taste that for me
wow
just gross and it's not hot either
that's partly the reason why they're not
coming back it's just watery
there was two strikes right away and i
was fairly confident that he would like
one of them at least
you're right fine
damn
there's
there's a lot of pain on mitch's face
batting zero yeah the big uh
whiff
see he just know what he's doing mitch
is [ __ ] up everything there
all right chef this is our broiled
fisherman's platter flounder scallops
and shrimp thank you
[Music]
[ __ ] it now my god oh boy that's gross
no good chef
soft bland rubbery i didn't realize it
could be this bad thank you okay
mitch can be playing again i'm not
kidding you he's [ __ ] yelling at you
all you have to do is do what i told you
yeah well i'm not you can go and you're
dead
oh no this was not good this was safe
the worst
worst of the worst till the end
no you're here 16 years so you think
your food is decent to hear otherwise
it's kind of shocking
i don't know if i'm gonna make it
through this
[Music]
nothing but isaac could be this bad
thoroughly disgusted with lunch
[ __ ] hell that's gross chef ramsay
wants to meet the chefs responsible for
this supposed authentic irish cuisine
come around this side please
so who's the chef mario
how long have you been here sir i would
say from 1997
did you taste any of the food that came
back yes i did you did what was your
thoughts i was it was okay you thought
it was okay
obviously because you're smiling
i'm embarrassed you're from ireland yes
what i had there today had nothing to do
with ireland
shepherd's pie well [ __ ] man that wasn't
shepherd's pie
if you went to dublin and you served
shepherd's parlor that they would shoot
you
the food is
embarrassing bland cooked dreadfully it
has no flavor
where's the pot of scallops where'd you
keep those right there show it to me
please
is that what you use out of mind
so
that's what you cook my scallops from
yeah
[Music]
are they frozen
they were frozen but they're not frozen
now
you've got no chance of cooking that
decent
oh my gosh
i was dying i was mortified it's not
hidden it wasn't a secret you just have
to go in and open a fridge
what's that in there
i don't think anybody walked into the
refrigerator or the walk-in box so
inspect it at all frozen everything's
frozen
that's what he's getting nothing's fresh
[Music]
hold on
maureen come over mitch come over please
what is that
how old are they they know they're all
good
that's two days old it's a funny two
days
how are you going to re-cook them
help me what are we going to do
you re-fry it
so it's fried twice
i want to throw up
there's not enough liquor in that bar to
get them inebriated enough to even
attempt to eat that is there any control
in here guys oh what is that
metallistics i can see that there blood
blood from where from the
blood from the meat on the mozzarella
sticks
come on guys thank god i didn't have the
[ __ ] mozzarella sticks look like a
blood transfusion going on down there
mitch when's the last time you went
through the fridge uh
talk to me please
i have not gone through this fridge
i left it up to my staff all right
i knew i had a problem with which as far
as that supervision was involved when i
didn't think it was as bad you know
you've got raw meat here
cooked meats
salami blood in there [ __ ] it come on
please don't do this yourself
let alone the customers
rule number one when learning to cook
you cannot store raw meat
and cooked meat on the same [ __ ]
shelf in the same [ __ ] fridge
the whole [ __ ] thing has got a
cross-contamination
chief give me something it's like a
supervision in here where's the rest of
the fridge okay this way that's what i
need to see
what's in there
chicken tenders why is it all bubbly and
slimy there's a chicken gum later the
chicken comes like that
look how slimy it is look how slimy it
is look at it
[ __ ]
my god it's horrific it's totally
embarrassing
what is this
how can you serve that
[Music]
it's like it's been left out for days
and it's been attacked by cats
this is where your money's going i
respect where the customers aren't
coming from but just from the base the
absolute waste i know because i pay the
bills let me just tell you now i would
never
never have put a spoon of anything in my
mouth if i knew this was taking place
shocking to see
just the extent of cross-contamination
there's no one checking sorry chief
you may be the chief but i swear to god
there's one thing that grasshopper
hasn't got is a leader
we should all be ashamed of ourselves at
this point in time i'd like to shut the
doors and just say you know what bring
it off someone's got to help me here a
little bit
i cannot help a situation who are not
willing to help themselves and you don't
need me to come in here and turn your
fridge upside down
mitch
if you're the one
with the hands-on role in this business
and you're supporting him and you're the
the mentoring figure
we're screwed
we have people coming tonight what are
we what are we gonna do i can guarantee
you one thing i am not
serving food tonight
with that [ __ ] in there
[Music]
no way
what's that in there
after a horrifying inspection in the
kitchen the whole thing has got a
cross-contamination
chef ramsay was left with no choice i am
not serving that [ __ ] in there
no way
i'm beyond beyond embarrassed about this
situation shutting down our dinner
service it's a nightmare we cannot
afford this and okay you want to open
fine of course i want business in here
but open with what
take one good look at yourselves and
[ __ ] think
i need some air guys
air and a stomach pump
we have never closed
uh for dinner ever i mean we've had 18
inches of snow outside and we've opened
mitch
there has to be leadership in the
kitchen what are you going to do tonight
i don't know what to say
well get in there and tell them to clean
that stuff off
guess what they're throwing out they're
throwing dollars out and guess who's
paying for it we are we're paying for it
what just happened here tonight was um
kind of a disaster
mitch knows that
this whole thing right now tonight is
his responsibility we can't serve any
food the way it is
the dinner's cancelled
in shock i'm drained emotionally i hope
this does not happen ever again
otherwise we won't be here mitch
that's
focus that's where it should have been
this is where you don't listen to them
and i said okay what are you starting to
fight with me now all right i'm just
saying it's right oh my that's where my
focus is but it takes an awake into
warren all right
bad news folks sorry we're not open
tonight there wasn't enough supervision
in there and i guess the [ __ ] has hit
the fan today i'm sorry about it oh
sorry about that definitely i'm
embarrassed as chief returns from
telling customers the restaurant is
closed
inside a leader has emerged to supervise
the cleaning of the kitchen mitch all of
this has to be thrown out but it's not
mitch
because the blood was coming down throw
it out get rid of it it's marine right
that has to go it's very upsetting the
food that's going into that garbage is
our profits for a while
and here we are in a situation where
we're not making profit
mitch this has to be thrown out this has
to go all right maureen all right all
right all right
everything was thrown away
disposed of scrubbed washed cleaned
and uh we'll start again
we're cleaning we're closed everything's
got to be clean
[Music]
after an eye-opening first day chef
ramsay realizes that it's not just the
restaurant that is on the line but mitch
marine's marriage as well
hi chef how are you good how are you
doing good tough day yesterday yeah i'll
say
well this is my home girl who's that
it's mitch
seriously seriously when was that taken
13 years ago wow
mitch and i back in the day we were best
of friends and through the years now
he's not the same person he used to be
and that's the hard thing
when you open that restaurant you got
married at the same time right the guy
i'm seeing today you saw that picture
that's not the same person you haven't
got your breathing space mitch's been
suffocated and more importantly the
man's getting destroyed on a daily basis
i
complained to my father when he does
like the busting chops and like breaking
him down i'm like how dare you so
there's me in the between you know what
i mean yeah it's fragmented to where
there's nothing constructive taking
place but
in mitch
i think there's a broken man there he's
spent
he works his ass off and what is he
getting what's his payoff
16 years in that business
and it's not right that we're in this
situation and it's our doing but we have
to make a decision on which way to go
the turnaround's gonna start today
[Music]
we need to start getting mitch back okay
and help him
ascertain some form of pride back in his
work honestly the turnaround will be
huge but i can't do that without you i'm
ready man as far as the business is
concerned and what is at stake it's our
family life i'll see you back at the
questions at the end of the day this
place can't control us it's time for us
to control it so whatever it takes
now convinced that maureen will give
mitch the support he desperately needs
chef ramsay heads back to the
grasshopper to see if the restaurant is
clean enough to open for dinner
[Music]
i hope chef ramsay will see a big change
in the way we're running this kitchen
today it's better than yesterday yeah
all right guys get set up for service
tonight i want this set up completely
okay
we learned from uh what went on
yesterday and
hope we get through it okay today
you need to be the leader i don't even
know if i can how i'm going to handle
this tonight
don't beat yourself up all the time
don't stop
myself that's right
[Music]
enough
mitch is gonna home he'll he'll give it
a whirl but he has to learn to be a
better communicator and um work together
as a team or else we're not gonna make
it
i won't pull through this
my god
while maureen tried to energize mitch
chef ramsay knows that years of
disappointing his wife and his
father-in-law mitch you're two seconds
yes sir uh take me the office please has
resulted in a complete loss of
confidence for mitch
are you okay am i okay yeah yeah yeah
okay tonight i want you to really
seriously yeah make it work
got to get this right
run it let them hear your voice
you wear your heart and your sleeve you
know that
i know i get emotional you know i can
see that i can see that i can see that
but relax
you can do this
the minute you find that voice yeah
they'll all back off yeah can you do it
yeah let's go let's go
after hopefully energizing mitch chef
ramsay turns his attention to the menu
okay mario let's go
adding two appropriate specials
authentic irish shepherd's pie and fish
and chips
okay color the vegetables nice and fine
so as it starts to cook it disintegrates
in the mince
salt please i know you don't use it
salt
salt
salt no yeah
thank you
season okay from there
mashed potatoes made with cheese
it it seasons it come on guys i want you
to taste it
shepherd's fire was awesome i was
excited about that i enjoyed it my staff
enjoyed it i hope the customers will too
okay the fish lightly seasoned flour and
you don't want to just drop it in right
no guys it's a piece of fish tell me
it's not a dish top crisp batter so
season it as it cools down chief what do
you think oh that's it we should do this
long time ago
two specials we roll with them because
i'm with you
you're expediting big time
i don't know if i'm gonna be the leader
but i'm gonna try i'm not confident
i just want to crawl into a [ __ ] hole
after refusing to open on night one i am
not serving that [ __ ] in there chef
ramsay strengthens the menu with his
version of a shepherd's pie and fish and
chips oh that's it now he is hoping to
get some encouraging signs as he watches
mitch and his staff during a dinner
service
excuse me
i haven't got a clue what you say is
that spanish scottish irish what you're
talking about if they say cheers we make
mayonnaise
cheese what
are you making the fish and chips buy
orders
what do you mean by order do you cook it
in advance sometimes no you're not free
cooking oh [ __ ] no they fry fish off in
advance you're kidding me jesus christ
you know the way to cook it faster a
burger takes 10 minutes to cook you
can't cook a burger faster when it's
cooked we send it
okay
okay here we go hello how are you
we have two homemade specials the
shepherd's pie and fish and chips i'll
have the fish and chips
in the shepherd's pie
fish and chips
mitch here we go first table's here yes
we're gone here oh where's the guy i
don't know where he's going it's timber
or [ __ ] island i don't know where
i'll get your wine relax told you stay
there i'm not going anywhere no way are
you anybody's [ __ ] tonight come on
i need one fish and chips special and
three shepherd pie specials cheers mitch
[Music]
mary's the only one that's listening to
mitch everybody got me anyway
hello down there
i need beer battered irish sausage and
chips
yes yes [ __ ] listen up i need a fish
and chips a shepherd's pie and a slice
steak
it appears as though mitch in the
kitchen are now on the same page and the
cooks are beginning to fill the orders
mitch where's neighborhood she say 40
huh i don't know how they don't know
afterwards she comes back
but chef ramsay notices another
potential communication problem don't
you have a copy of the tickets no i
don't have
an expediter needs the control of the
tickets
wow we haven't even got a decent eos
system
so there's the order i need that now
yeah just get it out yeah
there's confusion with the dupes all the
time because it's all handwritten it's
so antiquated it's just
it's ridiculous come on guys tickets are
fine
[Music]
rush to push food out just stop that was
the french onion soup little attention
is being paid to quality control
just stop for two seconds look we cannot
serve that
we cannot go to this extent
and try to start building a reputation
and serving that when you're the
expediter you're the last point of
control right so your standards are
there their standards are there you've
got to start putting in some structure
come on mitch please
this one here we're working on it chief
right now they're doing it
well get the [ __ ] out
these fish and chips 43.
after a slow start fish and chips
food is now making its way out to the
diners everything's good okay
and while the new specials are making a
good
dish impression the regular menu
isn't impressing anyone that's
disgusting
my apologies okay
that's so it's immediate well
and that's medium rare come on
another burger if you did well where's
the standards
come on guys how could you [ __ ] up a
hamburger i'm still upset
[Music]
medium yes
yes
[ __ ]
come here
all of you come here
touch it
it's [ __ ] raw
did you check it out come on
mario and all i want is a burger
a [ __ ] burger
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is going on mitch i'm
watching your mistakes see if you can go
outside and say hi to people no let's go
out all right we're not helping any
you're not doing anything here so what
good are you
two hours into dinner service and the
kitchen is beginning to unravel it's
soaked
this is ice cold with dish is that too
rare
would you mind just take that away for
two seconds i'm so sorry excuse me
we've got two seconds
is that
let me just tell you something when i
was busting my chops earlier making it
for you i turn my back for five minutes
and you send that out
chef
chef
come on guys on the back of
115 customers in two and a half hours
results for that
chef ramsay was just like to hell with
all of you there's no passion there's no
care for any of the food coming out oh
you [ __ ] get paid
where's the war on your faces if you're
my brigade i would have fired you
[ __ ] 16 years ago you you you you you
and [ __ ] you
the dinner service is now approaching
three hours it's
raw
and a steady stream of dishes has been
returned to the kitchen if you're my
brigade i would have fired you [ __ ]
16 years ago
chef ramsay is fed up and he knows he
needs to make an unusual move to save
this restaurant
hi
james it's gordon
yeah listen uh buddy i need some help um
i needed it quickly um
can you get uh yourself down here
the grasshopper please
ah
back inside the restaurant
what's going on with the last swan
the final orders of the night go out
thank you very much have a good night's
disaster
that was very brutal
shark and drained
tired
that was rough
a real freaking disaster
in there
they turn up they pick up the check and
they piss off home
they're not here for you
i realized i had to do something drastic
i've called so very talented local chef
and he just got here
james please this guy's worked at some
of the best restaurants in america chef
good to see you too
tomorrow
he's going to work with me and implement
a standard here
that needs to be put in place to move
forward
and by the way he's not only a chef he's
irish
tomorrow we re-launch
we stick together as a team and we kick
ass
i'll see you
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
after the arrival of chef james chef
ramsay decided to go ahead with his
overnight plan of giving the dreary
grasshopper a much needed makeover
good morning good morning good morning
today is the beginning of the new
grasshopper yes absolutely ready let's
go come here look
welcome to the new grasshopper oh my god
cheers
[Music]
my god love it it looks awesome yeah
it's it's absolutely
fabulous gone are the dark dingy colors
the green walls have gone very exciting
welcome to the new beautiful vibrant
color awesome the mahogany looks much
nicer with the champagne wall it's
incredible it's bright it's cheery
everything is beautiful mitch are you
happy yes i am yeah good morning you're
happy yeah
come on you guys have got to come
together yes thank you
we replaced the old stained glass we've
got some modern style lamp i love these
lamps made you happy did you put an
extra spring in your step it's great i
love it it's a breath of fresh air this
table beautiful a local artist designed
it look how good this looks in here this
is unbelievable it's positioned in the
center of the room so it becomes a sort
of focal family table this whole thing
has just got a breath of fresh air to it
okay there's life back in this place i
can't wait to see our customers faces
when they first come to see the new
improved grasshopper
i did make one more significant change
annette
put your hands on that box
you've been stuck in the dark ages with
this horrendous way of taking orders
this is now gonna make your life so much
easier
[Music]
extraordinary
amazing the state of the arts pos system
by payload can you imagine how much it's
going to change everything for us it's
going to make you so much more efficient
i'm telling you this is unbelievable
come here come here come here come here
you're an amazing guy
tonight we have got to make it
we have to be on top of it all tonight
mitch looked at me and he had tears in
his eyes and he said maybe this is our
opportunity the change in the decor will
make the grasshopper more inviting but
the most critical makeover has been made
to the menu gone are the greasy tired
uninspired dishes and in its place are
new vibrant irish-american dishes that
are not only pleasing to the eye but
rich in taste and flavor welcome to the
grasshopper new menu clearly smaller why
is it smaller quality controlling the
cost and trying to get consistent irish
potato skins fresh mozzarella sticks
corned beef for carrots and potatoes the
house burger with irish cheddar
shepherd's pie with the most amazing
mash chief especially for you irish l
stew unbelievable when he came along and
showed us that the irish menu of the way
and it made up and said this is it it's
absolutely gorgeous the new menu is
fabulous i'm really really excited about
it getting the staff a little taste this
food has spirit life to it so it'll
change this place
just like mama used to make it
chief you need to be honest firm and you
can't stop being fair and you call as
you said no no and they have to listen
to it you know why because you're wise
you've had success in your
life
there's only one chief and you're it
yeah okay
[Music]
hi folks welcome to the grasshopper this
is our new menu
the whole new menu just looks delicious
right i'm gonna have the potato to be a
potato soup shepherd's pie tonight chef
james will be behind the line overseeing
the cooks got all your sauces keep
turning and mitch who is desperate not
to repeat last night's disaster will be
expediting all right can i get a two
beer batter shrimp
lamb sliders
give me five give me five soups five
potato soups all day i got this you do
the soup come on okay you got to put
more parsley on this with chef james
controlling the line you keep that put
it in the window don't worry he doesn't
need to take it 41.
41. here you go thank you let's go
appetizers are moving out quickly to the
customers this is really good
thank you very much
now the pressure shifts to mitch to keep
the kitchen organized and the momentum
going all right just fire the uh
what do you have i need a beer-battered
shrimp and a pit and a ham and pea soup
can you can you call it again please
when i was watching mitch expedite i
noticed that he wasn't communicating
with a line the way he should have been
and
he was getting himself backed up that's
going to be this is going to get [ __ ]
up here
mitch come on
do you understand what i'm trying to say
yes
[ __ ] the entree he's gonna cook what you
tell him okay i'm sorry
i need a poor boy i need two poor boys
lamb sliders two shrimp puff battery
shrimp free battered shrimp
the first appetizers went out
brilliantly we have a real problem in
the kitchen and that mitch is expediting
you gotta get a system going just think
gotta get a system
this guy was an air traffic controller
he'd be landing planes at the wrong
freaking airport
appetizers while customers anxiously
wait for the food i think that might be
the only thing we might have tonight so
you got your food yet
chef ramsay is still waiting for mitch
to step up and take control of his
kitchen i have a fish and chips
an irish stool
is that a way or an order
oh come on
oh come on
come on
mitch you cannot do that to us
with the kitchen at a complete
standstill [ __ ] 35 sees their food dad
please a frustrated chief tries to help
out mitch out of the kitchen but it's
not exactly welcomed don't [ __ ] with me
shut up what are you telling me to show
you i said shut up that's not right get
out of the game shut up
[Music]
it's relaunch night at the grasshopper
come on and despite providing mitch with
a new tasty menu
and chef james to supervise the cooks
you keep that and put it in the window
don't worry he doesn't need a ticket
mitch's failure in the kitchen has
resulted in a battle between his wife
and his father-in-law shut up what do
you tell me to shoot i said shut
and chef ramsay has had enough we are
not going to continue along these lines
james
i'm sorry come round please
mitch i want you assistant james james i
want you expediting all right guys let's
go regroup
the first time in 16 [ __ ] years work
together yes start again
take over please chef i need those five
soups right away listen an assistant
potato skin you need this first right
now thank you all right that's going
well run it out there mitch run it out
there i am
finally i found a job for mitch he's
running food out
potato skins
what table number
how are you going with them
where are you going with the potato
skins
he's 22.
i was going with food and table said i
didn't order that pepper's pie oh no i
got pop no she got past though i was
going through all the wrong tables oh
this sucks i don't want to do this
anymore
table 40 runner please all right mix get
out
you let's go
we're making progress let's go chip away
at this chef ramsay's decision to move
mitch out of the kitchen and replace him
with chef james as the expediter guys i
have three tickets in front of me we're
almost there has completely turned
around dinner service customers are now
getting their food
and are thrilled with what they are
getting definitely coming back i'm out
of tickets so guys that's it all right
thank you very much
[Music]
as a difficult dinner service finally
comes to an end chef ramsay knows he has
to have a difficult conversation with
the owners
okay i'm gonna be brutally honest
this restaurant
will not succeed
unless you make the necessary
staff changes
and you can make it work
mitch
i know you weren't
professionally trained but it's down to
you
yes
i brought you james the expertise that
you desperately need to get this ship
back on course
take advantage of james
listen to him
do it
and do it quick
good night guys
change is scary good luck but we
got to take his advice and
make the right decisions
this has been one of the most toughest
nightmares i've ever done
because this ration has everything it
needs to succeed except one thing
a leader i just wish that chief was 20
years younger because right now there's
no one in there
that can fill his shoes
mitch mitch mitch mitch mitch
only days after chef ramsay left chef
mario was shown the door
house pasta shrimp only no veggies the
owners convinced chef james to stay on
as a consultant and properly train the
kitchen staff
and in the weeks that followed mitch
took chef ramsay's advice to heart
that's easy right and it's sexy fast and
furious
learning from chef james no bone for the
turkey burger and just fresh puts it out
and finally becoming the leader the
grasshopper always needed make it nicer
make it twice i have changed yes my
focus is a hundred percent in that
kitchen thank you folks everything was
good okay
[Music]
you